hi congratulations thank you there are
so many young screenwriters
dream about standing up there today what
advice do you have to say to them i mean
as tight as it sounds for me it was just
about telling a story that felt vital
and personal to me and writing something
that felt um
important and essential and uh
you know
write a lot and think about writing at
least other screenplays i don't know i'm
so excited i like that the idea of
giving advice i feel like to do this all
um
you know i think it interested me was
when i wrote tiny furniture i didn't do
very many drafts with it and i and then
so i had to make some kind of tough
choices in the editing room and so
really kind of through not doing a
million drafts it kind of taught me the
value of that practice so since that
i've been i've been a more
uh
rigorous
reviser
you're making a foreign to television
right now so how does that feel moving
from film to tv
i love the opportunity to tv because i
love the opportunity to stay with my
characters it's kind of a tragic thing
when you finish this you become attached
to these people and you kind of want to
see them take on all these different
places and activities and so there's
something really lovely about tv and
getting to really spend time and see
your characters
i mean i think that with this movie the
best advice that i got was
actually from my editor lance edmonds
when i wrote the scripture told me that
there was a lot of there was a lot of
dialogue and a lot of kind of
moments between people working things
out and he gave me the very simple but
important advice of how important it was
to see your character
so and right quiet moments and that's
what i think
how did you find the collaborators that
you worked with i actually met most of
my collaborators at this office film
festival so that was really amazing i
went there with another film that i made
and it was um
and it was
really incredible to meet filmmakers who
were
making small independent but very
thoughtful movies
i would like to keep using them i mean
my mom has like busy career of her own
and my sister is a college student and
acting is definitely not their first
priority but anytime that there is a
chance anytime there's a role that calls
for
a tall willowy
it's cold it's really cold and i was in
new york i mean i'm from new york so i
was excited to come here and like
it's bikini time it's not bikini time
oh thank you
thank you